glad to be with you it's the last day of
cultural appropriation month so you can
send in your costumes all of that and we
have some Supreme Court rulings coming
down I wanted to talk with you for a few
seconds here first day back on YouTube
it's June 29th if you're watching on
YouTube right now look
um I rarely ask you guys to to do
anything like this but a big part of
being suspended on YouTube is that the
algorithms now basically confirm you as
dead so in order to kick start that hit
the like button leave a comment once
this show is done streaming and uh you
know do that and then you can head on
over to rumble um this is something
that's pretty important here we are back
on YouTube
but I want to be clear as to why
um I've always said that the right
politician someone running for president
is someone who doesn't want the job
we don't really want to be on YouTube we
don't care if we get removed from
YouTube it's only a useful tool as it
relates to expanding our reach with the
truth
but the second that we are no longer
able to speak the truth in any capacity
and understand this is what they're
looking to do going into the election
right we were suspended with the last
midterms you've seen what's happened
with a lot of Jordan Peterson here on
YouTube so what happened with Matt Walsh
they're gearing up for the election we
don't care we know that you can leave
and head over to rumble anyway we're
using it as long as it as it's useful to
us
basically we want to be a thorn in their
side and use their own policies against
them and speaking of which I don't know
if you know this
and here's the issue is for everything
that you see someone talking about being
throttled Shadow band you all know that
we've been demonetized for years sure
there's something happening beneath the
surface
so for example Google YouTube they've
violated their own promising standards
when they're replacing these video ads
out there about 80 percent of the time
they're going to have a serious problem
with advertisers
uh
Embrace uh video music
[Music]
get us suspended so we'll probably run
that here during the break
these things happen behind the scenes
it's not what happens in the light but
what happens in the darkness and you've
heard of the term de-platforming look we
had Roseanne Barr on the show yesterday
the reason we were off YouTube for a
very long time is because we had the
gall to have Alex Jones on our show at
all
well guess what
we're still going to have Roseanne Barr
we're still going to have Alex Jones
we're still going to have all of the
people who YouTube and Facebook and at
one point Twitter tried to de-platform
because this is designed to be the
re-platforming space and it only works
with Mud Club if you do like what you
see watching The Daily Show you want it
on Friday you want access to nicked up
everything else Nick depaolo show right
Brian Cowan show is going to be coming
we have some major announcements
consider joining mud club.com
it's what keeps the lights on
but there needs to be an ability and
there needs to be a movement now
especially in the face of this election
don't don't doubt for a second
when people are discussing election
tampering when they're discussing
altering the outcomes for your country
and affects you we're talking about the
media entertainment industry industry I
sound like Joe Biden the media
entertainment government industrial
complex when you have the White House
saying Spotify needs to censor Joe Rogan
when you have marks up
[Music]
thank you capitulating to these people
is absolutely not an option but we can
only do that with you
you are the army
figuratively
and we have some major announcements you
know that in July we often take a break
we'll only be gone for two weeks the
next week is gun week you'll see a
teaser here where we have Mr guns and
gear single episode every day so Monday
through Friday we'll do handguns 101
rifles 101 gun myths
from gun control Advocates 101 then gun
myths technically 101 to keep you safer
with your Firearms which YouTube thinks
makes you an extremist understanding how
to handle a firearm but guess what screw
them all of next week Monday through
Friday and then some long-form
interviews the following week so we will
not be live through the month of July
but we've been working hard to pre-tape
and tried to figure out the best ways
again
to just be a thorn in the side of people
who hate everything you stand for this
is the re-platforming space this is the
re-platforming movement it's going to be
a barn burner going into 2024 and if you
do not join mug Club I just asked that
today you hit that like button on
YouTube Share comment whatever you can
do so that this is thrust into the feed
of people who YouTube Google Facebook do
not want you to see this content silly
costume notwithstanding on with the show
gun week coming up
oh baby
dependency loading operation Etc of an
AR-15
[Music]
that was nice
[Applause]
[Music]
it's June which marks louder with
Crowder's eighth annual cultural
appropriation month where we take you on
a journey to explore all of the
wonderful distinct and mysterious
cultures our great planet has to offer
because to appropriate is to appreciate
our final week of cultural appropriation
whisks us away to the biggest and
baddest state in the Union
home of hats that are way too large the
fastest growing economy in the country
and recreational swimming so renowned
people come from all over the southern
hemisphere to experience it you guessed
it we're heading to the great state of
Texas
us
why are you laughing oh the Rio Grande
thing yeah that's pretty bad I heard the
vo but I didn't it didn't make sense
till I saw the video hi YouTube We're on
your platform going through all your
private stuff you better come out and
pound me now
figuratively yeah we got all our
cultural appropriation month and we're
doing States this year for those of you
on YouTube weapons that we did New York
we did California we did Florida last
week is Texas because we ran out of
countries doing this for nine years yes
for eight years and I think it's
technically eight and a half there was a
half year what between there so
armadillo uh armed armadillo we just
wanted to change it I apologize let's
before I go through the costumes and the
fast facts that we have today look uh we
just had some Supreme Court rulings
these are Big deals Asians looks like
you're not getting the short end of the
stick anymore as it relates to
affirmative action
um I mean I wouldn't expect a Tony to be
you know like I'm a Duke basketball team
but you know look baby steps uh we have
the Allen Allen shooting a body camera
footage don't worry we're not going to
be showing you uh any innocent people
who are harmed I rarely use the word
hero but this man there was a hero
[Music]
thank you
I I don't know that can't be right can
it only 10 percent of Europe has air
conditioning and 90 there's no way
Europe really sucks all right uh let's
go to everyone here Institute we have a
number two CEO Joe I'm gonna put this
down just so you know everyone can see
that it's all ready folks I'm big ticks
yeah you are
I've had a little bit of an accident as
you can tell I don't know if you saw the
video of that is it do we have the video
big text all right let's see this
oh gosh well do I have to hold my hands
here still
well now it makes a lot more sense yeah
costume does yeah and you can send in
your costumes by the way to uh well me
on Twitter on Instagram obviously on mug
Club you can send them in we have the
costume contest winners of course on mug
Club after the show that you watch on
YouTube and are you hitting a ding
there's no ding all right and then we
have a you don't need to explain it
Hootie cheerleader I know you don't want
the attention on you and uh Yakuza what
are you wearing I'm Walker Texas Ranger
okay and then we have a toolman I'm an
ice agent and I get it bag agent I
didn't realize people were still paying
for giant bags of ice they are it's a
very common thing have you seen you see
this is the nugget ice makers those
fetch a pretty penny I guess people love
the little tiny the nugget ice in Europe
too because they don't have air
conditioners they do not have air
conditioning I still we're gonna have to
verify that statistic that's 90 of
Americans have air conditioning and only
10 percent of Europe and the death toll
is staggering oh my gosh we make all the
references available but even I still
don't believe it in third chair today
you hear the song you know who it is
[Music]
oh
we changed it it's not right tonight
through Saturday in Denver Colorado
you can go and see them briancallen.com
uh and who are you wearing well
um
I was told I'd be in a wheelchair and uh
that I got that via text we can't see
his legs he can't back the camera up
he's got
[Music]
gray hair you do yeah yeah you're gonna
gray well thank you you mean gray Moore
well yeah you know what that was the
joke this and I don't appreciate that
intro music I want the music that sounds
like I'm riding a horse yeah exactly
well you know what we'll get right on
that all right time for some more fast
facts regarding Texas because to
thank you
to appropriate is to appreciate all
right love it Dr Pepper was in fact
invented in Texas oh prune juice
it's still illegal in some cities and I
hope you look you guys on YouTube if you
if we don't have to keep doing this
it's a lot of work for something this
silly it's illegal still in some Texas
cities actually to sell limb burger
cheese on Sundays thank God this is true
that's a lot of cheese and it's also
illegal to possess six or more dildos in
the state of Texas did you know that yes
but joke's on you for that fast facts
rate was wrong it's five is that right
foreign
[Music]
going forward it doesn't blow out our
ears in the microphone that's true I
feel like tumbleweeds are softer did you
know this by the way I don't know it's
about armadillos is you cannot get
leprosy from them Brandy when she was
outfitting me she told me that and I
said I had no idea that I should be
primarily concerned with getting leprosy
from armadillos that's fair I didn't
know that was a concern that I needed to
have now I do thank you but they eat a
lot of ticks so that's good all right
foreign
[Music]
but it's not exactly what you would
expect they've permeated everything
[Music]
got a little boom in my big truck gonna
open up the doors and turn it up gonna
stomp my boots in the Georgia Mud gonna
watch you making me fall in love get up
on the hook
[Music]
foreign
it's a little
that's not real country Stephen came
around and started wearing skinny jeans
in the last five years to sell albums
I'm saying it's not cut well it was real
country until Tim McGraw came and ruined
it yes that's true yeah made what 50
million dollars off that Nelly song He's
like all right let me show up and get my
check just I can't go I'm not loving you
all right I'll be in there yeah I'll be
in the van
you think Travis Tritt's walking in here
with skinny jeans on no I have no idea
you always focus on the wrong thing all
right get him tight and uh what what am
I what am I looking at okay all right
let's move on here affirmative action
what do you got Gerald so the Supreme
Court did rule on the affirmative action
case we've covered this before how they
would actually weight it against Asian
people yeah I want to stop Asian hate
start at Harvard because Asians would
not be able to get in because they had
affirmative action to get more diversity
they would say so the Supreme Court has
ruled on that and a North Carolina case
as well saying that it violates uh the
equal protection Clause of the 14th
Amendment before we move on obvious
before The Supreme Court said it before
we move on there is a black lady on CNN
which of course is I don't see race uh
talking about affirmative action let's
see what they have to say here today I'm
still scratching my head as many
admissions officers will be so I can
take into consideration race as part of
the student's experience but their
actual racial group or category cannot
be contemplated or taken into account
you're going to have a situation that
has often been part of the admissions
process to quote-unquote equal students
perhaps in academic scoring SATs or acts
perhaps geographically perhaps even in
the instruments that they play so well
for the symphony and what will be the
deciding factors the court here today
says it cannot be raised but the other
factors could very well remain I'm also
curious to hear from secretary Lloyd
Austin what she just said is you know
scores academic performance
extracurricular activities it won't
include race but everything else that I
just named which is entirely reasonable
may be a part of the admissions process
yes yes two equal candidates are you she
literally just advocated for racism she
said two equal candidates everything
else being equally what is it going to
come down to well I know it's not going
to be race which it should if it's a
black student they should get in
overnight but that's not the issue too
that's not the lawsuit the lawsuit is no
I know but the lawsuit and a lot of the
arguments are that Asians have to
actually achieve higher academics way
higher that's the problem it's not
everything being equal it's even if one
outperforms on the metrics that actually
matter race can supersede that that's
what they're not telling you on CNN I
don't know if it's because she's an
idiot or she's lying it could be a
little column a little of column B they
don't use uh race a lot of times they'll
use lived experience so there's these
all these euphemisms and so your lived
experiment experience may be one in
which you didn't get the kinds of
opportunities blah blah blah or uh and
then that has to be taken into account
why why because that's the liberal
that's the Liberty yeah no I understand
lower the bar guys you're on the same
team the fight's out there damn it
you're right you're right I apologize
Greg who do you what were you about to
say yeah maybe I shouldn't demographics
on the chance of acceptability by Race
So it breaks down real quick uh Asians
12.7 percent whites 15.3 percent
Hispanics 31.3 percent blacks 56.1
percent
a lot of blacks whoa
56 to be fair I'm sure that all things
were equal
yeah that means uh black applicants in
the bottom 40 have a better chance of
getting into Harvard than whites and
Asians in the top 10 of applicants what
that's a lot of math but I do know that
it's racist
that's the do I have that right yes this
is incredibly racist this is look this
goes back to when I was
right the only only diversity they don't
care about is intellectual diversity let
me let me paint a picture for you before
by the way Biden's using a CPAP I'll
talk about that but
let me paint a picture for you do you
think that you will have a better
formative experience and by I don't
think college should be your formative
experience I think it should be life
experience I think it should be
preparing you for an actual path for a
job that exists but if you're saying
okay the experience creates this diverse
environment and that causes people to
grow all right you're on a campus where
everyone thinks the same you never hear
about the Constitution or certainly its
original intent you don't hear people
who advocate for the Second Amendment
the First Amendment you don't hear from
right-wing sources you don't hear from
conservative sources there are many
there's somewhere around 30 percent by
the way I'm going by Road here of
universities colleges in their
Humanities department they don't have a
single conservative on staff so that's
the school you go to but you have a lot
of black people and not too many Asian
people okay in the other world you have
people who got in an academic Merit and
you have because of that a natural a
natural sprinkling a natural sort of
formation of different World Views
of different perspectives where you
might have a professor teach you
something that challenges you maybe you
have one who leans right you have one
who leans left maybe you have somebody
who advocates for a flat tax maybe have
a professor who teaches you about a
progressive text maybe you have someone
who's a Marxist right now that's all you
have and maybe you have someone
[Music]
foreign
just got caught unless Gerald do you
want to come in with something good okay
using a CPAP it doesn't really matter
all that much it's funny but the reason
they had to address it is because photos
came out that where he had marks on his
face yeah he looked like the old guy
from uh from Mad Max
with the milking nipples only not as
powerful so the White House had to
confirm that former Vice President Joe
Biden uses a CPAP and here you go
President Biden has started using a CPAP
machine to treat his sleep apnea water
helps his stutter he's breaking details
here well now we know how he can sleep
and the White House just confirming that
that the president in recent weeks our
chief White House correspondent Mary
Bruce is told has been using a CPAP
machine to deal with his sleep apnea the
White House releasing this statement
I'll read it to you in full since 2008
the president has disclosed his history
with sleep apnea in thorough medical
reports he used a CPAP machine last
night which is common for people with
that history what they don't include is
that he was actually reluctant to wear a
CPAP at all until people in his cabinet
found a way to make it more comfortable
[Music]
to those listening on audio it's far
worse than the theater of the mind it's
so haunted creepy I got depressed
oh God this wheelchair was just no no it
doesn't help I cut right through the sad
of the wheelchair yeah that's a broken
wheelchair by the way don't try a
wheelie and Biden by the way when he was
asked about these marks on his face
um
he yelled at a reporter who also asked
him about this uh he wasn't asked sorry
he wasn't asked about the marks he had
the marks they're going that looks weird
Biden's face looks like a deep fake of
Biden's face watch this clip when he's
asked about Hunter during the China deal
he just yells at the reporter just
screams
were you in your thugs Chinese Shakedown
text message were you sitting there
where are you no no
no liar
that's about how he debate that doesn't
look like a real face it looks like it
looks like if the Phantom of the Opera
took off his mask and he had another
mask I forgot my backup mask yeah he has
trouble getting he has trouble getting
blood to his head yes he does and that's
hard you got a rub that's right above
the neck yeah no exactly and by the way
when he was asked uh why he was so
cranky he said that his CPAP was acting
up so he gave it to Hunter I went one
time for 13 days without sleeping
[Laughter]
operates is a great way to smoke crack
and makes you super mad at the Chinese
yes it does it does but you take their
money oh boy oh boy oh get on there oh
god oh that's a power grid I'm gonna get
on that yeah please Governor come on
I'll be getting on that all right just
give me a second hey there we go all
right right back I got on it I just pray
to God that this winter here in Texas we
don't get a slight chill can I just
bring something up very very briefly no
you never do
the White House said during recent weeks
he started using a seat
[Music]
this
foreign
raise his hand I just want to make sure
we're not missing anything because we're
good okay we're watching there are two
other decisions coming out of Colorado
Baker uh story that's coming back around
and then uh there's one more big
decision that we'll see about student
loan forgiveness okay well if you're
watching right now by the way again hit
the like button comment on YouTube
because the algorithm wants you to think
that this show no longer exists this
channel doesn't if you search Steven
Crowder change my mind abortion you'll
find a PBS clip instead all right
[Music]
so now that we have the body cam footage
um
is is a hero and they haven't
represented it accurately in the media
which again harms you so this brings us
to this week's good good guide with the
gun
[Music]
it's fun like that there's a lot of good
guys with guns thanks for helping me
while I was taking a sip I was hoping
you guys would take the ball I did I I
said something okay so you said I speak
too much interrupt your slurp the left
is uh is is misrepresenting this right
as though well look this is why only
police officers should have guns the cop
came and stopped us no this was a police
officer by the way with far more
training than you would see from a
standard police officer who was not even
responding to this call but waded into a
firefight anyway
um so that matters this just as easily
could have been a bystander with a
firearm because this was not the police
officer responding to that cult that's a
pivotal difference yeah you can comment
below if you knew that the media doesn't
discuss that and of course they're not
discussing it right now they're just
bitching about you know they're crying
allowed to get into college on the same
playing field so uh we don't show you
here we have a rule we don't show you
you know innocent people being being
slaughtered sometimes you'll see that on
shows they think it helps with clicks
but this is some body cam footage from
the Allen shooting and the only person
at whom he is shooting is uh the bad guy
who thankfully was uh you know assuming
room temperature when this man was
through so that's a happy ending uh but
still I wouldn't have if you have kids
there they shouldn't be watching here's
the body cam footage
145 I think we got shots fired at the
outlet mall
together so 3 36 P.M
the shooting starts
what you are about to see here is by 3
40.
this man had neutralized that threat
completely
he was responding to a different call
they're moving further away from me
that right there is a hero responding to
a different call he hears a gunshot
there's not a moment's hesitation he's
heading right into it
what yes
what you got
through them
yeah we got people coming
you can see from the body cam footage
handling his firearm properly
now this is pivotal watch what he does
when he shoots we'll come back to it
thank you
triple tap gun down
[Music]
back up control down
firearm back down
[Music]
finger off the trigger there this guy
knows what he's doing
I got him down nice
[Music]
this guy by the way was kicked out of
the military for mental health reasons
he actually didn't even go to basic
training
now I wanted to show you that in its
entirety because rarely do you see
someone who from what we've seen does
nearly everything right from
how he handles his firearm firearm
safety we'll be doing gun week next week
by the way going through those the ins
and outs
um to obviously controlling his firearm
obviously knowing how to shoot how to
aim if you actually look at the
percentage of shots landed just from
what we're seeing there that's
incredible to calling out verbally what
is happening telling other people to get
away right trying to keep people safe
and honestly how many of you can say
that
you would respond and wade into gunfire
at a moment's notice at a moment's
notice without any hesitation here's the
thing this police
[Music]
oh
boy went beyond the Call of Duty he
wasn't even responding to this call I'm
going by voice call me a racist if you
want clearly seems to be a man of color
why isn't the media scrambling to find
out everything about him and get his
face in the news we venerated George
Floyd we venerated Tamir rice Michael
Brown insert Trayvon Martin insert the
name here
[Music]
thank you
the right thing even when it wasn't his
job he had literally not been called to
do that I think it would be great for
young black boys
but it would be great for all young boys
why don't you know his name yeah comment
below and you know what I'm sure there
are some people out there who can who
can probably figure figure some things
out and at the very least this man
deserves a fruit basket if not a raise
absolutely like my my adrenaline's
rushing just watching that yeah like I
watched it last night with the sound
[Music]
foreign
hey you know what Asians should be
admitted that's a layup right now
nothing in the news
I don't know what the percentage is I'm
willing to bet many news outlets zero
percent it's a layup hey common
[Music]
can we all agree hey this is the kind of
action that you want to see from a
police officer if you don't see them
covering this there is no common ground
to be found and something that I think
is very important to note we talk about
[Music]
it's just as easily been responding
as a citizen as you right with an AR-15
in your car which by the way many
Americans certainly many Texans
absolutely have that's important to keep
in mind because the left will try and
frame this as a see this is why only the
police should have guns well let me get
let me fill you in a little bit do you
have any idea how how how inefficient
how unequipped so many police officers
are to deal with this in Texas okay the
proficiency for police officers the
annual minimum meaning you get to go out
and Serve and Protect you only have to
fire 50 rounds competently with a
handgun all year wow five rounds with a
shotgun all year 20 rounds with your
precision rifle all year
this is not a man who did the bare
minimum you do not get to be that
proficient by doing the bare minimum and
you know what most gun owners don't
either most gun owners if they go to the
range once a year they're firing more
than 50 rounds twice I guarantee it this
guy
it's the in between it's what he did
when he wasn't forced to you do not get
to be that efficient with a with a rifle
firing 20 rounds a year and I'm just
amazed that no one wants no one out
there is looking to commend him hey
nameless faceless
[Music]
thank you
thank you you are an actual hero well
you sing to the level of your training
so in a crisis people think they rise to
the to to the occasion if you haven't
trained you will sing to the level of
your training if you don't if you've
shot just 50 rounds in one year it ain't
gonna go well for you right or you might
you might but for the most part you have
a much better statistically if you
actually drill that and rehearse it in
your mind yeah and the one thing I have
to say is that guy is an absolute hero I
just wish there were more civilians
around who were trained who were armed
because that's the only way to stop a
guy like that we can the left will go
into mental health and that is an issue
they can go into the fact that we have
all these guns out there and that the
wrong people get guns sometimes legally
I think this guy bought eight firearms
legally I get it there are some
loopholes that are hard to close in the
meantime though I feel a lot safer if
citizens had the wherewithal to be
trained
[Music]
thank you
these arguments are absolutely silly and
understand the world that you live in
the reason that an AR-15 is very popular
by the way it's easy to control that's
why women love shooting It Gerald you'll
see next week in gun week was four for
four at 100 yards you'd never shot it
before then he missed with a shotgun at
point-blank range I don't know how that
happens it's a miracle
but you'll be able to watch I corrected
it I I got it on the second try
what a hero by that's that's a little
heavy so uh just to clear the palette
let's check in actually in in Dallas uh
to see what this uh tick tocker has
going on hi art today
a little field trip to this place called
the grass
and grab something but I really don't
know why
um I've even heard there might be ghosts
but I like haven't seen any so if you
know anything about ghosts let me know
in the comments below
um and there's an X in the middle of the
street I think that's
I can find bye oh my gosh I weep for our
society
this has been hey if you want to show
this guy you love him hit the like
button show them you love him even if we
don't know his name yet not all heroes
wear capes sometimes they're breathing
heavily and triple tap with an AR-15 God
bless him this has been this week's good
guy with a gun
yes Gerald all right so there's not
going to be any more Supreme Court
decisions today but we do have a clip
and I think a lot of people they all
tuckered out no they from the one the
whole one decision I think they knew
that this was going to make liberals
heads explode and they wanted to give
them time to actually do that yeah right
now all they're doing right now in the
media is crying but uh this is a clip
from Derek Johnson the NAACP president
and all he well that'll be fun listen to
what he says
worst thing about about affirmative
action is that it created a Clarence
Thomas who benefited for the Pro from
the program and now is in a position
where he's going to deny many young
African-American talented individuals an
opportunity his ah the worst thing about
affirmative action is that it created
Clarence Thomas oh okay thank you NAACP
president Jackson Brown whatever so
you're you're against affirmative action
no I am Pro yeah but I believe we should
make an exception for Clarence Thomas
who is clearly qualified and very good
at his job all right Mr Root scholar we
understand your position I believe lower
the bar I don't understand so so you
don't just lower the bar on admissions
that's so people people think like oh
well they're just letting them into
school think about racist that phrase is
right people are saying look I
understand your argument right and this
is what they're saying on scene I
understand your argument that people
regardless of race I mean in this case
specifically Asians uh if they reach
academic standards extracurriculars all
these things that are quantifiable that
they should be able to enter into the
University of their choice Counterpoint
how about we lower the threshold so
blacks can get in but but we keep the
Asian threshold higher than the average
right and that'll make black young black
people feel really good about themselves
yeah but but here's here's the thing
you're not just lowering admissions that
doesn't solve the problem because you
can easily have people that are not
qualified I don't care if they're
Hispanic black white I don't care who it
is if you can't carry the load
academically they have to lower the
standards of the University that's a
real and I don't have the numbers in
front of me but I believe that Thomas
Soul wrote about this there's a huge gap
as they lower the standards for
admissions the dropout rate yeah where
these people who and by these people
just be claiming anyone who couldn't
reach the original academic standards
for admissions they fall behind and when
they go into a program and they waste
that time it actually sets them let's
say student debt is added wasted time a
year two years and you can't make it
through the program all because some
white savior activists said no no let's
lower it to get you into the stem
program for which you're not qualified
the fake victim culture creates real
victims I want to get to the you were
sorry I cut you off yeah no but I wanted
to piggyback off of that point because
in Thomas seoul's book what he says is
they would have performed well at
another University these people aren't
stupid but they just aren't to the level
of maybe a Harvard or someplace like
that whatever
you're not the same problem so they
would go to another University they
would perform very well they would have
a ton of Confidence from that experience
and be able to get a great job and do
whatever do very well in a career
potentially whereas when they go to one
of these universities brick wall of
failure not able to carry the load
potentially and now it kind of sets them
back for life because they had that
experience that is not a good thing to
do to people I wouldn't have won I could
have gotten into Harvard with a 10 50 on
the sat right I'm not even kidding I had
an offer letter from Harvard full
scholarship because they do academic
scholarships and they were going to take
me with a terribly low SAT score because
I could play football I
[Music]
foreign
here's now you never told me you could
have gotten into Harvard with a 1050. a
full ride all right 100 oh my God my dad
Princeton Princeton Yale Harvard every
Ivy League school I could have gotten
into with a super it didn't matter what
my SAT score was this is why Gerald
pisses everybody off okay because rarely
is here's the thing the problem is he's
incredibly small he could have gone to
any Ivy League school right he played
football and did incredibly well in
order the problem is that he's
incredibly smart and sharp who
occasionally does things so dumb like
never finding in seven eight years of
the program a way to fit in his personal
story god well I did now I waited
I played the love like hitting four four
for four your first time with an AR at
100 yards and then missing with a
shotgun that is Gerald's life I thought
it was gonna
Princeton any of them yeah yeah and
Harvard I could have gone to DNK in
school you know
50. yeah I think it was I had to get
over a thousand like I didn't even study
for the SAT I literally walked in and
flip-flops after being on vacation for a
week took the test I think I got like an
11 20 or something like that and I was
like I'm out I don't need I don't need
anything more wow incredible good for
you I did the PSAT I was like top 10.
after the show and go through any other
interesting actors maybe maybe you just
don't think it's interesting yeah but
look yeah I sailed to the Galapagos one
time uh you know on a completely
motorless boat you know yeah but at
least look at him now he's dressed like
big tax yeah exactly burned big text oh
sorry did I see something else coming in
from Supreme Court from hoodie uh no no
there's not gonna be any oh there's a
Robert tweet oh my gosh
Robert Reich the Supreme Court's
decision to ignore the role that race
plays in our nation and how it shapes
our institutions and who is allowed to
participate in them is a major wrong
doesn't have a damn thing to do with if
you can carry the load academically
Robert nope you don't have your Society
of everybody gets to go to Harvard if
you want it but then it's not Harvard
it's something else it's dumbed down to
the lowest common denominator I'm sorry
not everybody's smart enough to get into
these Ivy League schools and perform
that's called the meritocracy
not everyone is on the path to go to an
Ivy League school and of course far
smarter than people in the ivy league
for example we don't do better in life
yeah exactly they could find you know
what's smarter than getting a gender
studies degree in an Ivy League school
learning a trade and starting a business
and there's nothing wrong again the
premise for all of this is hey you need
to go to to to to to University you need
the world of higher education that's the
ticket to success and it's a lie so they
promise it as the ticket to success
right
oh
[Music]
there weren't any more Mayors to sleep
well
all right
it shocks the sensibilities but here's
one too today and again it's very rare
that something comes across my desk I
know where I say are you sure this is
right
because it's so extreme yeah but all the
references are available at
lottoscredit.com so my question to you
is I kind of front loaded at the
beginning of the show but this will
probably go up as a as a clip what
percentage of Americans do you think
have air conditioning versus Europe okay
now comment below that's pivotal
ice agent the sunglasses make it hard
for you today you're not as quick to the
drop yes sorry uh
it really doesn't make sense to wear
sunglasses inside if you're an agent
yeah unless you've lived a good life bro
the reason this matters is because based
on the premise of climate change right
the reason for these heat waves a false
claim you have the left advocating uh
reducing or outright getting rid of air
conditioning right because of CO2
emission makes sense and when you
understand that that kills people to the
tune of thousands many many thousands in
the first world then you understand how
many people die in the third world that
we aren't necessarily even able to
quantify because those records are not
kept they're they're not tip top right
they're not airtight with their records
in the in the world that is third but
right now Texas is in the middle of this
massive Heat Wave it seems here to stay
in case you don't know here's a clip but
the severe storms doing little to bring
down the extremely high temperatures
across the state it's not what they're
designed to do you Heat Wave still
weeks away hundred or hundred five yeah
but it's got it yeah I have to work
doesn't matter San Angelo and Del Rio
Texas both yesterday breaking their
all-time oh my God temperature records
temperature was combined with high
humidity creating a dangerous
combination and just to be clear there
have been 13 deaths attributed to the
heat wave so I understand that we're all
sympathetic empathetic and we would all
like to reduce deaths due to extreme
temperatures of course correct
[Music]
foreign
so here we are the claim and I'm sure
you've seen this uh Brian is
this is naturally all the cause of
global warming
right
climate change yes wait yeah that's
right yeah I forgot which one they went
with that movie when Adam McKay created
that movie Vice and he tried to make it
seem like climate change was invented by
right-wing con right wing extremists
yeah Frank bunston is two paying
sneakers are you serious yeah it clearly
came from the left when they had extreme
cold temperatures now I have to watch it
and be angry so they have a solution
don't don't you don't you don't set an
appointment to get angry well what if I
want to be yeah well if I do I just set
an appointment with you so you can tell
me your personal stories
he watches it just to get some
motivation to work out yeah he could
have gone to Oxford as well it's really
strange God is that true yeah that's
another thing with Gerald you know he
went into the gym for the first time in
10 years and he put 225 on the bench his
leg was off the ground it was cock-eyed
and Cat he went but she's like I don't
know it's eight reps with 225 or never
touching a barbell in 10 years good
everyone's like we hate you next next
you'll tell me he's 6'4 yeah I know
that's what he says but he's actually
six five yeah
he's so humble and nice and I just want
to punch him and he can and he can run
you down I know so the solution run me
down the solution from the left here is
hey global warming right so if that's
your premise again think about it we've
talked about gun week if you start off
just a little bit Yeah off center well
if you're shooting in front
foreign
[Music]
going to miss a few years down the line
so their solution starting with the
premise of climate change is uh we need
to ban air conditioning it's expected
that four billion people will buy their
first air conditioner by 2050. great but
air conditioning itself is a major
contributor to global warming
electricity and can lead potent
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere you
actually will get into this pretty
strong feedback effect where you know
it's hotter people want more air
conditioning and it just gets you know
worse and worse we're saying the same
thing
yes you get into this except for the
lies that at this massive energy that's
not true I'll give you all these facts
because you know it gets hotter and
people want air conditioning and they
put in sad music like the theme from
Schindler's List like yeah it gets
hotter and more people want air
conditioning it wouldn't it be great
it's kind of Doomsday music though yeah
it is
air conditioner
yeah and that guy looks like he's uh
well conditioned air conditioned oh that
guy doesn't do well in the sun no he's
sitting in an air-conditioned space
right now oh he couldn't be wider his
his skin sees a UV ray it's 30 Days of
Night yeah these smolders
and nothing about John Kerry's private
jets no exactly so you're a super yacht
here's how Vox puts it and by the way
just to be clear NBC Universal the
parent company of Vox
um they're they're all carbon neutral
these Giants oh they are yeah they don't
they don't use energy and I'm sure their
offices are not air conditioned that's
crap so this is what they write what if
most what if the most American symbol of
unsustainable consumption isn't the
automobile but the air conditioner in
cool indoor spaces it's easy to forget
that billions of people around the world
don't have cooling no we didn't forget
it you do
and that air conditioning is worsening
the warming that it's supposed to
protect us from by the way shouldn't end
it with from but here's crazy math proof
okay uh people without air conditioning
die just to be clear
and by the way you know what makes it
less likely for people to have air
conditioning skyrocketing energy costs
yeah which of course we have experience
and if the left had their way unfettered
the entire world would experience
imagine if Justin Trudeau was actually
consequential do you have any idea how
much your gas would cost how much your
electric bill would be yeah put them in
charge of a major U.S state so see what
happens this step Twin Mills is shocking
okay and I I this is from the CDC the wa
[Music]
foreign
hit you in the teeth
702 in the U.S to Europe 15
000. wow wow that's 2.01 per 100 000 and
by the way the temperatures when you're
looking at the extreme for example you
want to compare apples to apples uh
Texas Spain you look at they're very
close they have extreme heat just to be
clear before you try and say that yeah
Italy now here's something so you go
okay so 10 times the amount all right
what's the big differentiating factor
and the reason we say the United States
to Europe as opposed to one European
country right thing we have Florida we
have Texas and we have New York state
right you have you have Washington we
have all of the climates so it's a more
accurate comparison as well as
population the households with air
conditioning
in the United States 90 percent
the households with air conditioning in
Europe
ten percent are we sure about that
Gerald sure so crazy they were a lot of
fans according to MIT Stephen according
to MIT according to MIT okay reputable
University yeah okay I just want to make
sure that we are correct sure yeah
actually we have a few The Washington
Post will also corroborate that CNBC
well they said it was five percent in
2019 as far as Europe doubled okay and
so yes and we're making all this
available the United States 90 of
households have air conditioning in
Europe is 10 so MIT Washington I just
want to make sure CNBC I have others
statista if you want to go down the list
a little bit all right and then finally
one of my favorite sites uh Mother Jones
Mother Jones confirmed this brother
Jones she's a yeah I don't like
her at all so hold on 90 versus 10.
that must mean that
[Music]
are we sure we're sure Gerald about that
100 sure about that number 90 versus 10
90 verses 10 and by the way sometimes
it's government interference Spain
wouldn't allow their residents to set
their thermostats below 80 degrees oh my
God that's like having a former military
dad it is and by the way only five
percent of homes in England have air
conditioning really
keep them toasty guys I'll be sluggish
so we can control them that's right hand
out popsicles once a year so you have 10
times a death rate that's okay in Europe
and you have uh you know it's more close
to about 700 to 15 000 yeah 715 000.
it's like that's like one million
percent but the solution is to get rid
of air conditioning right according to
the left because of the massive amount
of greenhouse gases okay so again let's
assume let's assume that let's say 50
right you might think that if you're
saying it's worse than Vehicles let's
assume that 50 of the Earth's CO2 came
from Air Conditioning okay okay we're at
the point
[Music]
foreign
missions and according to MIT man-made
CO2 only accounts for nine percent of
all of that in the atmosphere so that
means we have 10 times the death rate in
Europe where people less than 10 percent
of the population have air conditioning
so we know that lack of access to
centralized air conditioning to Modern
cooling methods leads to deaths on a
massive scale but we still want to enact
policy that will lead to more deaths to
the tune of hundreds of billions of
dollars probably trillions probably
zillions if you adjust for the current
state of inflation
that's what it would cost to eliminate
CO2 from AC and that would reduce the
total CO2 in the Earth's atmosphere by
0.35 percent
is that worth trillions of dollars and
tens of thousands of deaths 0.35 percent
hey we can't do these numbers because no
one has a consistent Source if you were
to shut off all air conditioning
tomorrow to reduce total CO2 emissions
by 0.35 percent all right
how many lives do you think that would
save
what would that do as far as an uh a
quantifiable effect a measurable effect
on the global temperature would it lower
the global temperature and eliminate
heat waves enough that people without
the air conditioning because you took it
away could survive hey let's say it
takes it down from a record high of 118
to
114 which no one is even claiming are
those people better off 17.8 yeah that's
right my two at the bottom I mean at
least you can do hot yoga
anybody they're already doing that you
would only have the choice to do hot
yoga saunas I don't know it's called
India all yoga in India yoga oh yeah but
but yoga in India in Hindu is means
stretch stop moving your legs Brian what
they don't work I don't know I just I
felt Governor they don't work healing if
a tree falls in if you want to be Daniel
Day-Lewis you have to earn that I know
it's true I'm a bad method you know what
they're not you know what they're not
taking into account in refrigeration and
this is Refrigeration so a big part of
air conditioning Refrigeration very
similar processes Refrigeration
typically is much more intense
Refrigeration is quite possibly the
single greatest invention in history for
man says you no I'm just saying in
general it might seriously if you look
into what it allows you to do with
medicine and food you can preserve you
can preserve this yeah I like to
preserve all of my Meats by drying them
and placing them in Saltines exactly
exactly so they're saying we should
probably get rid of that too because
that really is kind of a sub category of
air conditioning Refrigeration fits
neatly in that says they gotta just roll
back every invention that we've ever
made so you live in a world where you
don't have air conditioning let's say
you wouldn't have refrigeration okay and
uh they want to get rid of gas stoves
and wood oven and coal stoves in New
York so you have meat that has gone
rancid with no ability to cook it
live on jerky you have feces I like that
yeah yeah this is what we have to so you
can comment below does that that make
all of those numbers
ten thousand sorry uh 90 of the United
States to 10 of Europe 700 something
deaths in the United States due to heat
over 15 000 in Europe and if we
eliminated all air conditioning as
advocated by Vox as advocated by all
these leftist Outlets all the references
available.com we would reduce CO2 in the
world for a totally air-conditionless
Society by
0.35 no one hears anti-world anti-planet
we're pro-human
I like that they're talking about the
Supreme Court oh they're crying let's
see what they're saying this guy with
the Pugsley Adams haircut together the
majority was six each I just want to
read a couple quotes before we get to
our reporter who was in the room oh
really
look at the bottom of that affirmative
action has long held black
[Music]
by the way when we're talking about life
experiences we have a lot of Asian
friends and have had a lot of Asian
employees here Asian American employees
here uh I think you might be surprised
to learn that many of their life
experiences are quite severe it's okay
what's your I notice you have great
scores but what's been your life
experience what's the hardest thing
you've been through are you from an uh
inner city area well yeah yeah I am
urban area yeah not the wealthy sure
what else well
um
if I missed a versa in my piano lessons
my mom would jam the keys into my neck
and duct tape a bar of soap to my face
so CPS would be called by the neighbors
every five minutes
it's called the tiger mom we'll we'll
call you back she'd stand over me with a
rattan cane Yes again Boy again
straighten this life happiness in the
next what's the greatest adversity that
you as an Asian immigrant have had to
overcome here in comparison to the black
students
um okay do you see this size one foot
yeah are you familiar with the act of
Chinese foot binding yeah yeah well
turns out that it's not really good I
didn't know that until I got here and
saw a podiatrist but uh yeah that's why
I walk with a limp it's good for ballet
but I get it I get it I'm not from inner
city Detroit and I don't have an SAT
score 300 points lower are we through
here
you sure about that five minutes what's
that Hootie yeah the left is freaking
out we got a New York Times uh tweet
here breaking news the Supreme Court
rejected affirmative action at Harvard
and UNC the major ruling curtails race
conscious College admissions in the U.S
all but ensuring that Elite institutions
become Wittier and more Asian whiter
sorry wider and more Asian and less
Black and Latino he almost read it
Whitey Bulger
[Music]
good
everything
[Music]
thank you
spaces better if that is truly what's
happening we're not going to address
public education we're not going to
address single parent families we're not
going to address any of these things to
lead to lower outcomes educationally
we're just going to lower the bar
eventually for you does that do it for
you we're never going to change anything
so this is always going to be in place
racism is always going to be in place to
make sure you're okay I agree with
everything except gijn was a horrible
analogy because she did take control of
her situation that did knuckle
push-ups and then Jeff showed up for him
and she said let's do this and she won
shaved her head too she did and she
pulled the guy through the valley and
got him out barely got it
what you don't think to me more is
capable of that if a bird falls off a
tree
all right we'll continue keeping you
abreast on the Supreme Court but of
course it is cultural appropriation
month and we're doing Texas so that
brings us to this week seven plus one
[Music]
in the chamber
seven plus one best things about living
in Texas and uh by the way to anyone out
there if you are in Texas right now you
know you can comment on YouTube or of
course uh on Rumble hey leave a comment
on YouTube then head over to rumble big
old steam dump on the YouTube yeah all
right seven plus one best things about
living in Texas number seven we have I
actually have four seasons here no we do
wonderful so you get to enjoy the
experience of the changing there's
sweltering summer sweltering summer part
two ice storms and chiggers
that's a season yes unto itself it is
okay yeah those are the things that get
under your skin yes that's pretty fair
they don't that's false kind of like
liberals do that's hey hey see that guys
yeah
they release an enzyme
I did not know that I know because my
mom they burrow into your skin chiggers
what you do is you put nail polish on it
and that's the nail polish it's gonna
create a film and the is going
to suffocate but it turns out the
tigger's long gone and he's moved on to
biting my balls
dead I wanted to suffocate in your body
yeah she thought a lot of people think
that you have multiple stickers
burrowing in they don't it's more like a
they release an enzyme and then they
move on so everyone thought that it's a
mess so the enzyme itches or something
yes exactly it's gonna add the add that
soothing balm nail polish hold on a
second we've all gone way too far down
this Trail and there are a lot of people
not from Texas who are not familiar with
the term chiggers just to be clear it's
an actual thing it is yeah I know how
you think that sounds not a snipe no
it's a real thing chiggers just to be
clear I know how it sounds get your mind
out of the gutter I get a supreme court
just put you in a bad place seven plus
one best parts about living in Texas uh
number six Gerald in the summer you can
bake cookies in the front seat of your
car yeah that's true and you're infant
in the back seat well wow that is well
just be careful that's all be careful
that's what we're saying yeah unless
you've decided you don't sharing is
caring best things about living in Texas
number five Mr Brian Keller it is the
only state where the security at a
nightclub Pats you down to make sure
you're carrying oh well yeah well that's
yeah that's fun number four get in here
number four in Texas uh no shoes no
shirt no functioning power grid I'll get
on that problem
and those signs are posted yeah uh seven
plus one best things about living in
Texas number three Brian Callan baby's
teeth on the bones of smoked brisket huh
happens number two uh everything is
bigger in Texas but it's usually benign
so that's
what happens there you go and the number
one uh best thing about living in Texas
Gerald Morgan those brisket tacos that
Jill Biden mentioned oh we have a clip
understanding that the diversity of this
community as distinct as the bogudas of
the Bronx as beautiful as the blossoms
of Miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in San Antonio
cultural appropriation in my mouth you
know what I mean cultural appropriation
I love I love diversity in my mouth I
had to watch that through my fingers
yeah
the bogadas of the York you mean bodegas
oh I forgot there's always One in the
Chamber the plus one plus one best thing
about living in Texas it's the only
state with a governor who doubles as a
shopping cart okay you know what yeah
it's a shopping cart Centaur There Goes
My Career there you go no it's you're
just playing a character all right well
there you go that's been the seven plus
one best things about
Texas
[Music]
all right so look pretty good uh yeah
one thing that I want to talk about here
too before we leave uh before we go to
mug Club is
no Lord I'll get on that yeah I promise
all right little little we got it yeah
just a little talk hold on a second guys
we apologize quickly there we go we're
back we're back it's hot did you do that
with your mind I I have a signal I use
my fingers I go like that I go and I do
that and then my assistant knows he's
not Professor Xavier okay he could be I
can't use my legs so we're going to
continue by the way you can send in your
costume contest uh you can send in your
costume contest I guess I should say
entry uh Twitter Instagram but look
before we go here I know often we take a
break in July next week a lot of work
these people gun week where we have an
episode every single day and the
following week long form interviews
regarding climate change regarding uh
McKenzie and Company you've heard of
BlackRock you've heard of Vanguard it's
a time where we wanted to do a little
bit more of a deep dive and we have some
major announcements that we're going to
be making it depends on exactly when we
come back live it'll either be August
1st so two weeks away or August 7th
because there's some conversations
behind the scenes
um and this is the complication of of
really trying to fulfill the vision of
the company this is the re-platforming
place it's a place where people who have
been removed where people have been
throttled Shadow banned or people who
just won't get a fair Shake anywhere
else we're not trying to fit them into
the YouTube box that'll never work we're
not trying to get them back on Facebook
that'll never work and we're certainly
not going to punish them if they don't
play ball we want them under the
umbrella the safety the hedge of
protection with mug Club you you are the
Army and we want to re-platform people
we want to ensure
that people don't feel as though they
have to perform without a net that's
what we are working on behind the scenes
as well as some some other launches that
are pretty significant Gerald I do
appreciate all the work that you've put
in thank you sir there's a lot to be
done so August 1st August 7th depending
on who you will see darkening this
doorway ah I can't I can't I know I know
I get it it's exciting if you're
watching on Rumble hit that button right
there you can join my clip we're going
to continue for another 45 minutes to an
hour today we have the show tomorrow at
10 A.M Eastern uh we have Nick depaolo
Monday through Thursday five by the way
Nick thanks for doing the shows when his
his air conditioning went out it was 95
degrees in his Studio yeah but that's
what they want no no not Nick I mean
every all the leftists yes exactly
that's what they wanted
to do it just makes them angrier yeah
exactly an angry or Nick you don't want
that yeah it's it's if you didn't know
it was possible yeah yeah thank you very
much mug Club we'll see you tomorrow
Brian Callan is in Denver Colorado this
week briancallen.com continue watching
we're taking your chats costume contest
winners we're here for another two weeks
and see you in August
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]